it's obviously been
the most insane and traumatic time the
woman whose home was destroyed in anne
hatia's car crash speaks out her name's
lynne michelle and she explains why it
took her a week to break her silence on
the ordeal it's lynn michelle
um
still recovering and trying to figure
out up from down it's really truly
overwhelming
you guys have
really impacted my life in in
a very profound way
so thank you so much
to everybody and i will keep you updated
lynn previously released a statement
through her legal team
her lawyer telling et quote miss
michelle is devastated by what happened
to her not only because she and her pets
almost lost their lives but because all
of her property including items of
profound sentimental value were
destroyed
lynn takes a moment to show her dogs who
were unharmed in the wreck but says her
pet tortoise is being cared for after
being displaced that's three
and that's reuben
and they just want to say thank you so
much for uh cheering them on
um and my tortoise my friend kristia is
watching my tortoise so marley says hi
from the valley
lynn expresses her gratitude for the
love and compassion from around the
world after ann crashed her mini cooper
into lynn's la residence and set it
ablaze
l.a city fire tells us when the car
crashed it caught on fire and the fire
started spreading into the home
resulting in flames and a whole lot of
smoke ann died on friday but the video
came just hours after the actresses rep
told e.t she was on life support and was
not expected to survive and has
sustained life-threatening injuries
these are the most serious injuries that
we see
in burn care
e.t spoke with a burn specialist who
gave us his professional opinion on the
long-term effects of anne's condition
whenever you're in an enclosed space
like a car or an apartment or a house
that allows smoke and chemicals to build
up
which damages the lungs and prevents you
from breathing on your own so the only
way to survive is to have mechanical
ventilation artificial breathing for you
on a machine we're told anne's family
was keeping her on life support in order
to see if her organs could be donated as
her rep explained in the event of anne's
death it has long been her choice to
donate her organs
[Music]
you